welcome
everyone thank you for joining our
presentation
today titled lateral flow manufacturing
strategies and scale
up towards point-of-care testing it is
my pleasure to introduce to you
dr chris franzek application scientist
bio dot incorporated for a complete
biography on our speaker today
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following at the end of the
presentation
please join me in welcoming dr chris
fonzak
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
hello i'm chris and i'm an application
scientist with biodot
i'm going to be discussing lateral flow
manufacturing strategies and scale up
towards point of care testing
a little bit about biodot we are a 26
year old privately held company
we supply systems and solutions to
various marketplaces from
lateral flow diagnostics to life
sciences to clinical
we're very customer focused we're
collaborative
in nature we're very application focused
our global headquarters is in irvine
california where all of our
manufacturing and quality
is done recently we opened uh
east coast of the united states location
in hillsboro north carolina
we have european office in the uk a
chinese office
in shanghai as well as distributors
worldwide
we focus on a variety of markets from
point-of-care tests to cytogenetics
molecular diagnostics and even medical
and industrial
however we really got started in lateral
flow devices
particularly in the last eight months
we've been very heavily focused
in manufacturing of cobit 19 tests
the lateral flow device manufacturing
process
can be subdivided in a couple of
different categories
first is the deposition of reagent what
i'll refer to as dispensing
this involves depositing antibody test
and control
lines on nitrocellulose membrane
treating any sample pads or wicking pads
beforehand
and depositing gold conjugate on the
conjugate pad
next is drawing of all layers
and then assembling the layers in a
process called lamination
before cutting and assembling
lateral flow manufacturing can be
subdivided into
batch manufacturing and inline
manufacturing
batch manufacturing is smaller scale
production
from initial r d to
hundreds of thousands of devices per
year inline manufacturing is
higher throughput to millions of devices
per year
and this talk will focus not only on
each one but the process of
transitioning from batch to inline
when considering reagent deposition
there are several critical factors which
must be looked at
first and foremost is dispense volume
and accuracy
this is critical for the development of
sensitive tests
volumetric accuracy should be within
plus or minus three percent of the
desired target volume
with better than five percent drop to
drop precision
dispense position along the membrane
should also be considered
often times reagents must be
within plus or minus 50 microns of the
desired position
this is important to avoid region
overlap
in addition to for for example tester
control line
emission because of overlap
for these more challenging applications
vision systems
or fiducial markings can be used it's
critical to avoid cross-contamination
particularly to avoid false positives in
testing
this can be accomplished through
non-contact dispensing
it's important to be able to work over a
wide
range of fluid reality from blocking
buffers to gold conjugates to antibodies
in addition to some more viscous
concentrations
typically this process will be
over a wide dynamic range from
nanoliters to microliters per drop
of reagent however newer applications
including high density microarrays
and lateral flow often require picoliter
volumes
dispensing technology should be scalable
from hundreds of thousands to tens of
millions
of tests per year it's also important to
work with different arrangement of
dispense nozzles
to create custom patterns
there are a variety of dispense
technologies
used for this reagent deposition which i
will
talk about in detail aerojet
is used to deposit gold conjugate
biojet is used to deposit antibodies
front lines also used to deposit
antibodies the differences biojets
non-contact
prolines contact and for those
aforementioned microarrays
piezo dispensing technology can be used
for those smaller volume drops
the air jet is a syringe pump driven
aerosolizer
which is used for depositing gold
conjugate onto fiberglass
it's syringe pump driven making it
highly accurate and precise
it's capable of operating over a wide
volumetric range all the way up to 24
microliter per centimeter
the flow rate is controllable and
adjustable
through the adjustment of positive air
and the spray width is adjustable
making it possible to create a more
dense or wider cone
across the substrate all of these things
lend to a very consistent aerosol
as is shown here on the left
of air jets and various arrangement
spraying gold conjugate onto fiberglass
membrane
all of these dispensers that i'm
discussing allow for independent control
of the spence channels
which further lead to the lack or
avoidance of cross-contamination
here's an example of a custom
arrangement of air jets
used for completely impregnating
fiberglass with different
gold conjugate air jets can also be used
for
impregnation of material for blocking or
sample pre-treatment
biojets are also syringe pump driven
they are used for the deposition of
antibody testing control lines
reagent is taken from a source bottle
guided through a syringe pump
micro stepping from the syringe pump
delivers
a said volume to a solenoid
which opens and closes based on a
specified
open time this simultaneous coordination
of
microstepping and a micro solenoid
firing
creates a proper kinetic energy to break
off a drop of liquid
onto a substrate this works over
a large dispense range anywhere from
two nanoliters per drop to two
microliters per drop
working in multiple modes typically for
lateral flow development we will be
looking
at on the fly meaning drops will be
deposited
to create a tight line and motion
and dispensing are coordinated without
stopping
for certain applications particularly
arrays step and repeat
is also an option to create these
patterns
where a motion is temporarily stopped
between dispensing
as with the air jet there is an
independent control over each
dispense channel and unlike the air jet
because there is
independent control over a syringe pump
sitting in a micro solenoid setting
the user can adjust the dispenser for
different
fluid realities and this is very
critical for drop morphology
reagent sources can be bulk meaning they
start from
a container or for r d level work
the syringe pump can be reversed to
aspirate
from for example a micro tighter plate
all this lends itself to high dispense
rates
pictured on the right are four
independent bio jet channels
these are the solenoids these are the
ceramic tips
here is a video of two bio jet channels
dispensing
test and control line on 25 millimeter
wide nitrocellulose
this is at a fairly moderate dispense
speed
this is an example of on-the-fly
dispensing where
drops are pitched tightly to create
concise lines
on the right is an example of a raise
and lateral flow
three different bio jet channels
dispensing arrays on the fly of 20
nanoliter drops
the speed shown here is 30 millimeters
per second
however the speed can be run
at a more vigorous 60 millimeters per
second
which is shown here
each one of these arrays would represent
a separate test
frontline technology is another type of
technology
used to deposit antibodies
unlike the biojet dispensers front line
is contact using flexible
tips made of peak material
syringe pump delivers a quantity of
volume in contact with the membrane
and the tips drag or glide across the
nitrocellulose
for more specialized applications piezo
dispensing can be used
for example to create multiplex lateral
flow arrays
these include arrays that are sometimes
quantitative for a test or perhaps
test which otherwise would be ambiguous
piezo dispensing works over pico leader
to low nanoliter
range for drop dispensed driven by a
piezo element
this is typically used to aspirate but
also can be bulk fed
for certain larger scale operations
high density arrays can be created as
shown here
and just because this is piezo does not
mean throughput is sacrificed
some advantages from this type of
dispensing first of all
are the ability to create geometric
symbols
alphanumeric symbols and this tends to
lend itself to
better quantification higher sensitivity
while
lowering reagent use
in order to create these specialized
arrays
software and an easy to use
graphical user interface is often
required
a pattern can be easily created
which then leads to the creation of
these symbols such as the one shown
on the right
when considering dispensing of reagents
it's also important to consider quality
control
during dispensing
control often requires some type of
vision application
this can be achieved using a camera to
look at
membranes during the dispensing process
as well as a bad part marker
to use some type of feedback mechanism
to
blot out any section of membrane to be
discarded later
for dispensing these vision applications
are often used to look at line
position with and integrity as shown
here
this is critically important because
poor line integrity
can lead to ambiguous results or false
negatives
but also line position can lead to
bleeding of reagents or
the excise or overlay of that line
during lamination this is also very
critically important for array
based applications that require a reader
window to fit on
this type of vision application can also
be used for conjugate
primarily looking at conjugate width
position and even concentration
besides dispensing vision qc is also
important during lamination primarily
for position and overlap because
if the overlap is too great for example
in building up a lateral flow device
a test line can be lost or a control
line can be lost
and when considering reagent deposition
and vision and quality control
it's important to put them in context of
batch production and inline production
for batch production materials are
typically pre-cut to length
membrane can be pre-laminated prior to
reagent deposition
or the individual layers can be
processed before lamination
batch production usually is in the
context of r d
to low level production typically less
than one million tests per year
developed quality control
while sometimes automated is usually
manual
this is a picture of a batch level
system
for reagent deposition capable of
depositing antibodies on nitrocellulose
and spraying gold conjugate through an
air jet
any sample pad pre-treatment or blocking
and sometimes even conjugate
impregnation is accomplished using some
type of
tray for dipping and all materials are
dried in an oven
drying is typically the rate limiting
stop
a small laminator is used to assemble
the test
to make layers as shown to the left and
a guillotine cutter
is used to cut strips to the desired
length
often the goal is to start in batch
level manufacturing
and once a process is set to move to
larger scale
production however there are many things
to consider
in this transition first of all
material selection oftentimes
and this is true in cobit 19 testing
certain materials are chosen for higher
sensitivity results
however these materials are often
brittle
thin and sometimes have poor tensile
strength
when considering inline manufacturing
sometimes hundred meter rolls of
materials
need to be tracked so tensile strength
is very important
in addition for web handling and
tracking
the design process should transfer
easily to manufacturing
not just from a dispensing perspective
in a time perspective but also from a
process perspective
for example transitioning time from lots
a lot or batch to batch or even
application application
and drawing drawing again is the rate
limiting step
in the batch level manufacturing
materials are often dried overnight
however in-line manufacturing
drying needs to be faster
it's also important to use equipment
that can be transitioned easily from
batch to inline
manufacturing fortunately
the dispensers that i discussed earlier
do just that
in looking at inline high-level
manufacturing
materials are continuously fed
from a payout module to a takeout module
this is typically using the on-the-fly
dispensing that i mentioned earlier
this provides for great process control
including
continuous drawing inline qc with vision
and precision alignment due to tracking
here we see a series
of syringe pumps these are tandem
meaning two pumps feed one line this
allows for continuous dispensing while
one syringe is emptying the other one is
filling that way the process never has
to end this
is in the context of higher volume
production capabilities
for example at 50 millimeters per second
100 meters can be treated in about 34
minutes
this is enough to produce 20 000 tests
per year
built-in environmental controls are
possible both in the dispense module as
pictured here also to the take-up module
the whole goal of this besides
increasing throughput is to reduce
waste and to reduce qc time
here is an example of an inline system
for dispensing and drawing a system like
this is capable of producing
up to millions and tens of millions of
tests per year
a roll of material is fed and driven
through a series of dispensers the
dispensing is analyzed
via qc potentially with feedback
oftentimes impregnation for blocking is
included
material is fed through forced air dry
towers
and then rolled up on what we call a
take-up
in addition to the features
i just mentioned on the other slide
other features can be added depending on
application
for example for poor tensile strength
material
ultra low tension options are available
which reduce
inertial force on the membrane
humidity control enclosures can be
included around dispensing and take a
module
and for many applications where moisture
is critical
a moisture sensor can be added inline
a newer trend in inline manufacturing is
plc systems
in order for proper control monitor and
communication between each of these
modules
not only does this allow for everything
to be controlled more centrally
for example this system to this system
but
also for more proper data collection and
feedback
here is a video of a reel to reel 120
feeding nitrocellulose membrane as shown
here
being driven through a system
of biojets dispensing five
antibody lines
these tandem pumps ensure
that the process has never stopped
now this is nitrocellulose for conjugate
a separate process would be used on the
same system where fiberglass would be
fed to that air job
here you see five lines on
nitrocellulose
being analyzed with inline
vision and a bad part marker before
being dried
and rolled up in the takeout module
following
inline region deposition the layers are
assembled into a test and a process
called lamination
auto lamination
includes web speeds up to 100
millimeters per second which is highly
dependent upon what material being run
as well as the number of laminates or
how complicated the test is
this process is designed for quick
alignment and changeover that way
multiple products can be run on a single
system the system
is modular it's flexible it can be run
with multiple applications
and these modular units can be added and
subtracted from the system later as
needed
typically after lamination
the finished layers are fed to a cutter
for cutting
these can be first fed to master cards
in a reel
to be transferred or cut in line
here's an example of an auto laminator
from left to right a module
laying backing card down before
being laminated with nitrocellulose
containing anybody testing control
lines then having
a conjugate pad added these layers
can then be analyzed with vision for
overlap and precision
before being laid with cover tape or
barcode
in this scenario either
the tests are cut in a guillotine cutter
or rolled up
for a downstream process
here is a video of an auto laminator
the backing material with the take-up
liner
the membrane payout with tracking and
take-up liner
and three material layout in this case
including conjugate
the vision inspection
the cover tape payout
and placement before
the cutter
cap stand for tracking and driving
and the take-up reel in addition to
basic lamination
barcode labels can be added for the test
and provision inspection recognition
after lamination cards can be collected
and stored instead of cutting or the
final assembled test can be rolled up
[Music]
the last process prior to
bottling or packaging is cutting
these are a couple of the cutting
options besides the guillotine cutter
in this scenario a rolled up test can be
fed
to a cutter to create specific lengths
these cutters can be used
with various sensors including a target
sensor for fiducials
in this picture a bottle collector is
added to the end of the cutter
to collect the cut test strips
here shown is a cutter
that is used in batch level
manufacturing
pre-cut cards that are laminated are fed
to a cutter
and then bottled in this picture
a rolled up laminated test is being fed
to a cutter
which then sorts into two different
bottles
besides the standard lateral flow test
that contain testing control lines it is
possible to create multiplexed arrays
and geometric symbols
besides multiplexing this can
lead to more sensitive quantitative
tests but also qualitative tests
to eliminate the possibility for any
ambiguity or
create a certain message
multiplexing can be done at the batch
level or inline web handling
in a high throughput manner oftentimes
this
is continuous however for certain
complicated arrays indexing is important
at a high speed that enables
multiple arrays per second to be created
region handling is critical in
particular
oftentimes higher concentrations
or more viscous samples are required
typically this process is going to be
using
picoliters to nanoliters
as opposed to microliters as shown here
in 50 nanoliter spots on nitrocellulose
positional accuracy is very critical for
this
particularly for multiplex arrays or
require some type of reader
for this reason fiducials can be used
often with a vision system
and software is used for editing an
array which is particularly ideal
when looking at r d level manufacturing
here is an example of batch level
multiplex array
which include pre-cut card
various dispense channels dispensing an
array
created your revision program
this process can also be adapted to
in-line manufacturing
often times with the ring for example
here is a schematic
or a concept of material being fed
into two separate dispense modules for
indexing to create these
more complex arrays before being dried
this concept also shows in line
lamination
and cutting and bottling which would be
the ideal process
oftentimes customers choose to separate
these out that way
multiple lots in addition to multiple
tests
can be developed
when looking at multiplexed arrays
particularly in smaller volumes
qc is especially important for inline
manufacturing
because it's critical to know exactly
when to make a cut and when to dispense
arrays
for this reason fiducial markings are
also used
these fiducial markings not only
allow a cutter to trigger cuts
as needed down the process as well as
lamination
but can also be used to trigger
dispensers
to deposit a very specific pattern
within a certain window
thank you for your time
and thank you dr forensic for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
and as a reminder please submit your
questions uh in the q and a box
okay our first question is um
can you give some specific examples of
arrayed lfds
um so array lfds are not nearly as
common as the standard
lfds stripes with single lines however
typically we'll see multiplex
tests that require a higher level of
sensitivity
that can be matched up with some sort of
a reader and one of the big advantages
of the array is that the customer
can use less reagent and also save costs
on the test
uh in particular i have worked with a
couple of these
type of irate lfds in the past that deal
with
the detection of certain toxins such as
anthrax
wow okay thank you for that and the next
question that we have
is what have what has been the biggest
challenges
when manufacturing cobia 19 tests
so the nice thing about our dispensing
technology
is that
going from different types of tests
different types of biochemistries
is often directly translatable since we
can kind of tune for different fluid
uh realities and properties in all
reality the biggest
challenge that we faced is customers who
are
pretty new to this arena to lfd type of
tests
jumping into the covet arena with some
of them little experience
uh the other part of that will be a lot
of customers
who have been more in r d
type of manufacturing jumping to inline
for cova testing so it's mainly been
assisting customers kind of making that
jump in a very short period of time
which has been very common in the last
eight months as you can imagine
thank you so much dr funzak and i
have a few more questions here uh
how many tests per year are possible
when batch
manufacturing
uh typically and this is really heavily
dependent upon the actual
process we have seen
a single system manufacturing in the low
to mid hundreds of thousands of tests
per year
um in order to really get closer to the
million
tests per year it usually requires uh
maybe three ships a day and often
multiple pieces of equipment and at some
point
it usually makes more sense to just
scale to to the inline
type of equipment for that so usually
it's gonna be in the in the low to mid
hundreds of thousands maybe up to about
500 000
thank you so much and our fourth
question
today is what is the most challenging
lfa
application bio dot
has experienced
so typically it's going to be one of two
scenarios
number one
it's often pretty common to select
certain
materials particularly
very thin on back nitrocellulose which
is often good
for higher sensitive type of tests
transitioning from batch to inline
where web handling is critical using
those type of materials with tensile
strength is is challenging
uh the other challenge is and really
kind of what i mentioned the talk of
the the time limiting step is drawing
particularly when when
depositing a high volume of reagent
so often a challenge is to
find a scenario where we can keep a very
high throughput
but also making sure materials are
tracked properly materials do not break
in line and materials are dried before
they are
assembled in a single test
thank you so much and our last two
questions there here
is what is typically the biggest
challenge when transitioning
from batch to inline manufacturing
uh pretty much the
the answer i just gave uh it it's mainly
drawing
um but but really developing the process
around
continuously uh processing
tests for you know an hour or so as
opposed to doing
batches it's really adapting a process
and making sure that
that when developing a batch process
it's
easily translatable to in line without
having to go and reinvent the
reinvent the wheel
wonderful okay and our final question
today uh is how common doctor forensic
is it to combine dispensing laminating
and cutting
into a single inline process
the answer is it's not very common
usually lamination
and cutting are combined
the problem again usually is drawing
sufficiently
particularly when running at a higher
speed for good throughput
uh the other thing is is that a lot of
times customers are running
multiple types of tests so it doesn't
make sense to have everything in line
that way they can easily switch over to
what has to dispense
and then at the same time they can be
laminating and cutting for another type
of test if that kind of makes sense so
usually it's not very efficient plus
um an inline system that combines all
three would be very long
so it work it would require quite a bit
of space usually
instead of having a nice you know long
process like that it usually makes sense
to stack
systems side by side for space purposes
thank you again dr franzak and
unfortunately we are out of time for
today
if you have any questions that were
submitted and not answered today
uh by our speaker we'll be addressed via
email
and thank you for your outstanding
questions
to the audience and the presentation
will be available on demand for viewing
in
for 12 months please remember to share
it with colleagues who might be
interested in today's topic
and don't miss out on other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
thank you